Jason what's your advice to directors on
directing actors ah well my my advice
for directors on directing actors you
know the III was find that less is more
and I find the more direct directors can
be when they're talking to actor is the
better certainly you know I've been on
both sides of that equation obviously
I'm an actor as well so I and I find
that I find that the more the more
delicate a director tries to be the more
frustrating it is for for everyone
involved I find the more direct you can
be and the less you can say the better
the better you are the better the better
it is for everybody
interesting so you're not sort of
tiptoeing around trying to know just
some direct and concise you know I I
find me as a director and me and maybe
it's because I you know I'm so you know
I I understand the secret language of
actors because I'm one as well but I can
go up and just say one word to an actor
and and I know go Oh got it okay good
and and that's it like the less you can
say the better interesting okay how was
the process for you reading a script as
a director different from you
reading the script as an actor yeah it's
it's it's entirely different you know as
an actor your focus is very is very
myopic and and and you know when I when
I read a script as an actor I'm you know
obviously I'm focusing on the character
that they're approaching me to play in
in the piece so although I am reading
the entire piece my focus is on is on
that one character because as an actor
you approach you approach the piece from
from the point of view of your one of
your character because you have to and
as a director you know I'm reading the
script as the entire piece because
you're your phone
because as a director is the is is the
entire piece and and and of the piece as
the whole because you're responsible for
the whole thing so so so you know it
really it really comes down to to the
difference in the focus of the two
crafts as a as an actor your focus is
very finite and in very in in very
myopic and as a director your focus is
very broad and very all-encompassing and
it has to be so for Cass and Dylan which
is your feature directorial debut how
many times did you read the script
before you said yes to the project
I read the script twice before I said
yes to the project that's all it took I
was I was I was very taken with the
opportunity to to tell this story on a
on a grand scale I was as a young man I
I made a journey from Winnipeg Manitoba
to Vancouver British Columbia with my
father actually yeah when I was about to
when I was about 10 years old so I was
very familiar with that with that
landscape and that and how that
landscape changes and and how that how
that color palette changes as you drive
from east to west across across Canada
so I so I you know once I was invested
in once I was invested in the characters
and the story I knew I knew the story
that I wanted to help visually as well
because it because you know that part of
the world and the way that the way that
it changes from the prairies to the
mountains to the to the coast is is such
such a unique and impressive change you
know I really I really wanted to to
impress that upon people and seeing that
it is a road movie did you shoot it in
sequential order I mean was there stuff
that you shot out of turn um you know
it's a movie so of course there was on
fortunately you know we we tried our
best to to shoot it in sequence because
you always do but unfortunately things
things never seem to work out that way
but but I did you know III did do I did
do a lot of things that that ended up
costing us costing us time which of
course drove our producers crazy you
know I was I was constantly you know we
would shoot something on the on the
trailer in the in the in the in the
Volkswagen that we had on the trailer
and then I would you know get off the
trailer and shoot you know shoot the
shoe run buys in stuff in the car
because I you know I really wanted the
you know the the run buys and the in the
end the stuff in the car in the car to
match the visuals that were they were
happening outside the car because you
know I you know there's you know there's
sort of an old Hollywood thing where you
know what they would say yeah you know
you shoot all the stuff either you shoot
all the scenes in the car it doesn't
matter where they are like people are
gonna notice what's outside the windows
but but I believe that people do really
notice what's outside the windows with
whether they're really noticing it would
consciously with their eyes that like
they notice it subconsciously and they
and they especially especially you know
because we were we were going through so
many so many different topographical
areas in this movie like I thought it
was very important to to shoot the
scenes that were happening in the
prairie shoot them in the prairies and
the things were happening in the
mountains shoot him in the mountains and
things that were happening at the coast
shoot him at the coast because it
because it was you know there's such
different areas and the lights so
different and the colors are so
different and so I so I really I I had
I'd if I had to fight for those things
but but it but I really wanted the
audience to feel like they went on this
2,000 mile journey with these characters
and and I wanted them to feel as wrung
out at the end of the movie as the
characters felt and and I think that I
think that the audience does feel feel
that and and by the time by the time we
get to the third act of the movie I
think the audience is
is-is-is as exhausted as these two
characters aren't I think that I think
that that that decision that I made
plays a large part in that